es gibt viel viel Gegenwind für diese
Forderung diesen Vorschlag von Bayerns
Gesundheitsminister Klaus holetschek
also sprechen wir mit ihm direkt jetzt
hier bei Bild live und zugeschaltet kurz
nach Weihnachten Herzen bekommen bei
Wild Life AeroLogic
Route von Kassenärzte Chef Andreas
Gassen war sie stellen das solidarische
Kranken Gesundheitssystem
Krankenversicherungssystem damit
komplett infrage
nein das will ich nicht Solidarität ist
ja die Basis die darauf fußt und ich
glaube man muss das einfach
differenziert sehen dass das nicht
einfach ist auch in der Abgrenzung ist
klar aber ich glaube das Thema eines
Rauchen Zelt des is ja eine Sucht der
die daneben nicht eher individuell
ausgesteuert wird es kann man nicht mit
der Pandemie vergleichen und von daher
glaube ich gibt es schon Unterschiede
ich habe heute einen
Diskussionsvorschlag machen und habe
gebeten dass man das prüft ob das
sinnvoll ist und jetzt sind wir in der
Diskussion drin und ich nehme da vieles
Erkenntnis das auch Zuspruch von vielen
Bürgerinnen und Bürgern kommt aber das
auf Funktionäre sich dagegen stellen ich
habe nicht gesagt dass dass die ultima
ratio ist aber ich denke man muss in so
einer Situation doch auch mal über
solche Dinge nachdenken aber wie sollen
sich die Menschen das leisten nehmen wir
mal an jemand der nicht wirklich viel
Geld verdient möglicherweise gar kein
Geld verdiente landet auf der
Intensivstation mit Coronavirus
monatelang womöglich beatmet sind das
sind Kosten enorme Kosten die da
entstehen das kann man doch gar nicht
selber tragen
also wir müssen doch erstmal vom
anderen. Ausgehen wollen wir eine
Impfpflicht ich bin der Meinung wir
brauchen die ich war lange der Meinung
gebrauchen sie nicht aber inzwischen
glaube ich kommen wir um das Thema
Impfpflicht nicht herum die Frage ist
wie setzen wir die durch mit welchen
Sanktionen da gibt es Thema von
Bußgeldern auf David sich dann die Frage
stellen wie es das machbar oder auch mal
die Idee zu sagen können wir andere
Mechanismen anwenden dies übrigens sind
Sozialgesetzbuch ja schon gibt in den
Paragraphen 52 SGB 5 gibt's ja diese
Leistungseinschränkungen dass das nicht
einfach ist ist klar aber wenn sie nimmt
Pflicht haben dann müssen sie irgendwann
den Menschen ja auch sagen wie setzen
Sie die um und mit welchen Sanktionen
ist die wer haftet das heißt sie haben
ja jetzt sich alle entschieden diese
Impfpflicht einführen zu wollen durch
den Bundestag muss das doch durch aber
sie sagen ja seit langem sie sind dafür
und jetzt merken sie müsste jetzt können
wir das eigentlich gar nicht
kontrollieren wir kriegen das eigentlich
gar nicht durchgesetzt was sind
eigentlich die Sanktion dann wenn jemand
sich weiter verweigert das hat sie das
ist im Grunde der die wissen gar nicht
wie sich durchsetzen wollen
ja doch es gibt die Überlegungen das
z.b. Bußgelder verhängt werden können
ich habe jetzt einen weiteren
Diskussionsvorschlag eingebracht mal zu
überlegen ob man sein andere Tatbestände
aus dem Gesundheitswesen anknüpfen
könnte des habe ich gebeten zu prüfen
nichts anderes diese Diskussion muss man
jetzt führen im Bundestag über die Frage
der Impfpflicht da geht's ja auch weiter
in die Frage des Inf Registers auf das
ist ja ein Teil des Themas und natürlich
über die Frage der Sanktionen und da
gibt's unterschiedliche
Anknüpfungspunkte aber klar ist doch
eine Impfpflicht ohne Sanktion ist ein
zahnloser Tiger
wir leben im Moment bundesweit auch in
München ja heftige Proteste von der
kleinen Zahl aber doch die ja immer
militanter wird sozusagen die auf die
Straße gehe da auch dort Polizisten
verprügelt von Leuten die sich ja
tatsächlich weigert sich impfen zu
lassen über so lange Zeit die werden sie
damit nicht kriegen durch höheren Druck
wahrscheinlich aber die werden sie
weiter provozieren durch sowas
muss doch über die Dinge reden können
wir sind in einer Pandemie und die Frage
des Impfens ist keine Privatsache aus
meiner Sicht Sonne ist noch eine Frage
des brennt und des Gemeinschaft Schutz
ist Solidarität in der
Krankenversicherung ist wichtig aber
Solidarität ist natürlich keine
Einbahnstraße in einer Gesellschaft und
wenn wir uns grundsätzlich für die
Impfpflicht entscheiden dann müssen wir
auch wissen wie wir sie dann durch und
umsetzen und um des geht's viam lange
glaube ich versucht mit Argumenten die
Menschen zu überzeugen wir seit ich
immer noch für das beste Instrument
übrigens die Menschen aufzuklären zu
informieren zu kommunizieren aber wir
merken doch wir sind jetzt an einer
Stelle wo wir glaube ich die andere
Diskussion führen müssen die Curt in den
Bundestag und dann muss man auch wissen
was kommt auf mich zu wenn ich mich
weiter nicht impfen lassen will wenn ich
mich nicht impfen lassen kann dann
brauchen wir immer individuelle Lösungen
darum geht's ja nicht
helfen indem Fall wahrscheinlich nicht
mehr an die 30% jetzt immer noch nicht
geimpft sind wäre es nicht einfach
cleverer das Feld anders aufzuräumen von
hinten aufzurollen zu sagen wann zahlt
den die jetzt immer noch nicht geimpft
sind einfach eine Prämie damit wir diese
endlich gar nicht erst brauchen
kann man auf das Thema seines Bonus
überlegen es gibt ja in der
Krankenversicherung schon die Boni auch
beim Impfen wird es ja schon teilweise
mitgedacht auch das ist eine Möglichkeit
wie gesagt ich bin da offen für die
Dinge ich bin bloß dazu darauf zu sagen
wir brauchen Lösungen und müssen klar im
Vorhinein auch sagen was ist denn wenn
die Impfpflicht kommt was heißt es dann
für den einzelnen der sich nicht impfen
lässt und wie setzen wir die durch und
um das gehört auch zu Fairness und
Wahrheit dazu dass man vorher dann diese
Schritte auch mit kommuniziert sie haben
richtig viel Gegenwind jetzt für ihre
Vorder und ihren Vorschlag ihren
Einstieg in diese Diskussion bekommen
aber sie haben gerade gesagt bei uns die
haben auch ganz viel Zuspruch bekommen
von wem denn auch von ihrem
Ministerpräsidenten auch von Markus
Söder
es gibt von Bürgerinnen und Bürgern
Zuschriften die sagen ja ich sie finden
es richtig dass man auch diese
Diskussion führt es gibt auch
Zuschriften die die das tatsächlich für
nicht richtig halten es gibt beide
Seiten einer Medaille noch mal man muss
auch in einer Pandemie einfach über
sowas mal diskutieren können wir sind
noch mitten in einer sehr sehr
schwierigen Lage mir geht's doch nicht
darum jetzt zu spalten sondern mir
geht's darum zu sagen was sind die
besten Anknüpfungspunkte in dieser Frage
einer Impfpflicht dass wir eine
Impfpflicht brauchen dazu stehe ich und
dazu glaube ich es sind auch viele
Diskussionen schon geführt aber jetzt
geht's doch in die Frage auf der
Durchsetzung und mal drüber nachzudenken
ob dieses Thema des Impfens tatsächlich
ein Thema ist dass man mit anderen
Bereichen im Gesundheitswesen verbinden
kann das ist legitim diese Diskussion
muss man jetzt aushalten wenn man zu dem
Ergebnis kommt es ist nicht sinnvoll gut
dann muss man eine andere Lösung finden
habe ich verstanden AeroLogic die Frage
war ja wie sie mit ihrem Chef wie sie
mit Markus überall drüber diskutiert
haben also unterstützt ja da
also Markus Söder hat zu dem Thema
Impfpflicht ja gesagt dass es für ihn
wichtig ist dass die kommt und das auch
glaubt dass die die Gesellschaft ihr
Verein und ich bin mich auch mit ihm
einig dass eine allgemeine Impfpflicht
wichtiges nicht nur diese sektorale nein
es geht spüre da ja jetzt im Moment auf
die Diskussionen aus dem Wege also würde
er habe sie mit Chrissi sein Vorschlag
den bin ich jetzt in das ist ein
Vorschlag den ich jetzt ins Gespräch
gebracht habe und wie gesagt
Designvorschlag wenn Sie meine
Stellungnahme genau lesen dann geht's
darum das zu prüfen ob es sinnvoll ist
und nicht mehr und nicht weniger wollte
ich damit als Aussage tätigen
eine
Nachricht heute erreicht hatte ist die
aus Berlin der RBB also eine ARD anstatt
der will am kommenden Montag die Zweig
Regelungen für Mitarbeiter vor Ort
einführen das heißt also wer nicht
geimpft oder genesen ist der muss zu
Hause im Homeoffice arbeiten das ist
rechtlich sicherlich nicht ganz
unumstritten ist das auch eine Idee für
Bayern
das würde im Moment bei uns nicht
diskutiert in diese Richtung wäre mir
ganz klare Regelungen zu diesem Thema
die da sind das ist die 3G Regelung und
ich gehe davon aus dass die weiter
Gültigkeit hat was andere Bundesländer
da diskutieren das dazu kann ich im
Moment nicht sagen
das ging nicht um die Bundesländer
sondern eine Sendeanstalt
ins Büro teilen können wir hoffen alle
dass diese Wand nicht so kommt wie sie
jetzt prognostiziert wird und dann wird
man auch sehen ob man weitere Maßnahmen
braucht er viele haben ja nicht
ausgeschlossen dass weitere Maßnahmen
notwendig sind auf der
Bundesgesundheitsminister nicht ich
glaube wir sind jetzt mit den Regelungen
die wir haben uns dem erstmal ganz gut
da und alles weitere wird sich ergeben
danke an Bayerns Gesundheitsminister
Klaus holetschek der eine gewaltige
Diskussion angestoßen hat höhere
Krankenkassenbeiträge für ungeimpfte das
ist die Frage und dieser Diskussion hat
sich Klaus holetschek hergestellt bei
Wild Life danke dafür
können